ああお部屋が汚い明日掃除するんで今日は許してください
こんにちははじめ社長ですつかれてですよん
入っちゃったらもう岩上に疲れていて体が全身的にもう気がしているような気分なん
ですね今そんな僕なんですけども
今後はこちらバンソーコキズ版ですね救急版ともいうからなんていう語
正式名称だね上残ってたみたいでもうまとめて買ってくれ買ったに後で300な
そちらでわかってるみたいなそう修理甘くった湯へ登って段階説でているのでていたぞ
カス悲しかったろー呼ばやらこんな ob で止められて売れなかったんだと思います
この形なんで僕がまとめて来ず版を一つ200枚入ってます
絆創膏を1100枚準備したんですけども絆創膏の高官級等知ってるからそこはジホン
的にはそのチーズ
ですね怪我とかしたい一力 s 3ケースや靴ずれなどのえっと汚した床を保護する案
走行
受け継ぐ家にばい菌とが入るしていたりケガを治すようなものなんですけどもこれは
このバンソコウニンさらなる可能性を感じ体に貼るとてがが治るよずに体が回復すると
いうわけ
たね僕が考えているのは今ここにあるキッズ
岩船米を体中に果てて俺の体全身的に注力を max まで上げます精神的に9幕の太
るって体中の注力それで max くらいのレベルになる体の回復で中国が高いという
ことは俺の体の疲れが一瞬で
とれるー
ざーろんやってそうはないと思う
それでまず日焼けの後バトルてね体中が使ってきてる僕なんですけど用い力回復力を
最大限まで上げて瞬間的に回復しますよ
まずは壮大ですうん
me
もちろんせ何してんの
ぜひま
ちょっと身体時に絆創膏貼るぬ手伝って欲しいんだけどさ
ぞそれ以外
変えて今すぐ来て
お願いますが来てだこれで思ったね多分一人だと1日かかるんです
me
ん例えば誰かの為じゃなくあなたのターンに
たあーじゃんいいん
me
ん
fanic
me
t you do 何ございます
うわーっ
本そうですねかいうめっちゃ痒い